à la demande du gouvernement le sénat
est appelé à se prononcer par un vote
sur cette déclaration
conformément à l'article 39 alinéa 6 de
notre règlement il va être procédé un
scrutin public ordinaire dans les
conditions prévues par l'article 56 yeux
règlement il n'y a pas je vous le
rappelle d'explications de vote
les secrétaires catherine d'euros chez
agnès canayer vont superviser puis leur
place
le déroulement du scrutin
s'il vous plaît est ce que le scrutin
est ouvert
le scrutin est ouvert
voilà donc un scrutin public est en
train de s'effectuer de façon
électronique voilà les sénateurs à
l'issue de ce débat avec notamment ce
débat interactif qui n'avait pas eu lieu
à l'assemblée nationale la semaine
dernière avec 15 questions réponses vont
donc être amenés à voter sur la
déclaration du gouvernement déclaration
tout à l'heure à 14h d'edouard philippe
le premier ministre qui a parlé un petit
peu plus qu'à l'assemblée nationale à
environ 1h20
parmi les annonces à noter notamment et
bien cette aide pour les jeunes
précaires allocations pour les jeunes
précaires de 200 euros pour huit cent
mille personnes
notez aussi et bien les nombreuses
inquiétudes qui ont été soulevées par
les sénateurs notamment sur la question
de la responsabilité des élus locaux
voilà le scrutin est clos on va pouvoir
connaître le résultat d'une minute à
l'autre
notez-le cela risque d'être extrêmement
serrés notamment avec l'abstention des
du groupe et l'eire qui a été annoncé
tout à l'heure on va écouter de les
présidents du sénat qui porte le numéro
sans contenu l'ensemble des délégations
de vote accordés par les sénateurs au
gros politique est notifiée à la
présidence le nombre de votants 1344 le
nombre de suffrages exprimés 170 pour
l'adoption 80 contre 89
le sénat n'a pas adopté je vais
suspendre la séance je crois savoir que
la commission des lois a besoin de se
réunir pour examiner l'exception
d'irrecevabilité